nbc sports on peacock which starts every
day with this man's show it also ends
with pft pm mike florio back here on the
rich housing show how are you mike
rich i'm doing great pal how are you
today what's the story of week 14
what's the story of week 14 so far the
story of week 14 as we had a week 14. i
know that right not let's not bury the
lead
right we don't know i mean think if if
we would have
known in august
how dire the numbers
would be and i know that some people
don't want us to talk about that too bad
if we had known how bad the numbers were
going to be in mid-december
we'd have said there's no way they get
the football season and there's no way
they don't miss game there's no way they
don't have to postpone or cancel or work
major surgery on the schedule
to try to get in enough games to justify
a postseason run there's no way
so it really is amazing and it speaks
more to determination than anything else
that the nfl decided
doesn't matter who's out doesn't matter
how many guys are down we're gonna play
football
it's next man up it's always been next
man up and that's what we're gonna do
and but for a couple of times where
we got a little nervous about where
things were going tennessee and
baltimore
it's worked and it's amazing that it
worked because when you look at the
broader context of what we're dealing
with as a society
it shouldn't be working but it is so
yeah again
it was uh all teams back from there by
and so it was the busiest sunday we've
seen since week three which was before
the buy and no one else had anything off
and there were no
uh cancellations or delays yet as we
know the week four game between
tennessee and pittsburgh was the first
one that had to be
maneuvered around so there was a whole
host of games yesterday
um and jalen hurts doing what he did
where are we going to hear that it's his
gig the rest of the season and then
that's the end of that i mean
because it was definitely a much better
not just the result wins but everything
else mike
yeah how can it not be his job the rest
of the way last week jason kelsey the
eagles long time center
had some very frank and raw comments
about
how the failure of the offense is a
total team
production the players the coaches
everyone that it's not just carson wentz
everybody stinks so when you change out
one position and all of a sudden you
have your signature win
you beat the saints who had every reason
to keep winning because they were
holding on to the number one seed by a
very
slender margin and now they're not
that's impressive
and so whatever it was you did yesterday
you keep doing i'm stunned that doug
peterson
wouldn't come out and state the obvious
of course it's jalen hurts how could you
go back to carson wentz
at this point and the question is how
far can jail and hertz take them
and how clear will it become by the end
of the season
that come 2021 there's no competition
there's no presumption it's going to be
once
it's going to be hertz and they're going
to spend the full off season
trying to build an offense around the
guy that has shown he can come in and
and save a lost season and i got jim
irsay coming up uh
an hour too uh mike and the reason why i
bring that up is everybody basically
assumes well
philip rivers is uh you know uh gonna
need
toe surgery he's already got his high
school coaching gig
all set up that he's going to be done
there and that's a perfect spot to send
carson wentz send him there frank reich
was the m might have been the the real
guru on that uh sideline for wentz
do you think it's as simple to connect
those dots
i think it is and here's the reality
step number one for the eagles and this
is
a general rule for any effort by any
sports team
to trade a player step one insist you're
not trading the player
that's how you get the best possible
leverage otherwise maybe you have to pay
some of his salary like the dolphins did
to unload
ryan tan hill onto the titans maybe
you've got to send a second round draft
pick like the texans did to
get rid of brock osweiler's contract
several years ago
so you have to create the impression
you're sticking with the guy you still
believe in the guy you're not going to
trade him
and then you hope that someone believes
it i don't think anyone will their best
hope is to get two teams interested
to get the colts and someone else
interested in the litmus test for me
rich is very simple when frank wright
the head coach of the colts who was the
offensive coordinator of the eagles in
2017 when wentz
was on track to be the mvp but for the
torn acl he suffered december 10 of that
year
if wright doesn't want him that's the
ultimate red flag that no one else
should
and and so we'll see how it plays out
but it makes a ton of sense for wence to
end up in indianapolis if you'd have
polled colts fans back in march and said
one year 25 million who do you want
rivers at once it would have been
unanimous once
and now yeah circumstances have changed
but i i think that
that there's value in this idea that
maybe reich can reset the clock for once
he just needs a fresh start
and maybe if you get out of all of that
pressure
in philadelphia from circumstances from
fans from everything
maybe he can rediscover himself and then
just uh
just sticking with the eagles for a
second here just in short term what
hertz might be able
to do the problem for philadelphia is
the horse
could be a little bit too far out of the
barn in the nfc
east that they were leading for the
first half of the season when everyone
else was trying to get their sea legs
because the washington football team has
six wins
and you know washington looks amazing on
the defensive side of the ball i mean
just
absolutely spectacular chase young
defensive
rookie of the year candidate you know
jeremy chin obviously
uh doing what he's doing in carolina but
this kid chase young is amazing
alex smith however went down what can
you tell us about
smith who washington one would think
clearly needs certainly with seattle
coming in for week 15.
what do you have for ron rivera the
coach of the washington football team
said after the game it was a
precautionary move to take alex smith
out which is surprising because
they had created the impression they
have no faith whatsoever in dwayne
haskins
so i i i believe
that it was precautionary when i see
that for example alex smith fully
participated in practice on wednesday in
advance of next weekend's game so
you know look coaches are kg and coy
about this kind of stuff and it makes
sense you don't want people to know what
you're doing at the quarterback position
for as long as you possibly can keep
them in the dark but
you know you mentioned the eagles last
year rich they were five and seven and
they found the gas pedal and they ended
up winning the division the problem is
they got to jump two teams this year
right not one they got to get the giants
and washington that tie is either going
to
save them or kill them you don't worry
about tiebreaker when you have a tie
so they're either going to win that
division by a half game or potentially
lose it by a half
game but it's going to take a ton of
work steve kornacki had all the
percentages last night
and the eagles don't have a great shot
at this point
and in in large part because they need
two teams
to lose down the stretch not one mike
florio pro football talk right here
on peacock right here on siriusxm
channel 11
211 and also later on today pft p.m to
wrap up the day
on nbc sports on peacock right here on
the rich eisen show
um the firing of paul gunther um in
vegas means both defensive coordinators
standing on the sideline when car hit
uh rugs uh eight days ago are now both
gone where where did that come from and
and you know what what do you think the
raiders
uh are going to do for the next three
weeks with this positioning
right now well when when chris sims and
i were talking about this earlier today
he made a great point it doesn't happen
that abruptly without some sort of an
incident something like what happened
with mark columbo
and joe judge the giants former
offensive line coach
and current head coach respectively from
last month but
i'm told there was no incident that it
was just a phone call last night to paul
gunther that it's done that it's over
it is kind of confusing they've beaten
some very good teams this year they held
the browns to six points they've lost
mainly to very good teams
except for that blowout in atlanta where
the offense had six turnovers so it's
kind of hard to fault the defense
but you know could this be just changing
the subject a little bit
taking some of the focus off of the fact
that the offense isn't getting it done
it feels like something beyond
desperation they had a small chance to
make it to the playoffs
with gunther and now rod marinelli comes
in with three days
before the next game thursday in that
game i think it's unheard of to see this
kind of a move made on a short
week you make it on the other side of
the short week you have extra time
to get the the next guy ready so this
this
just feels like an impulse move
by a coach who maybe doesn't have
someone there who can really say to him
in a moment like this
don't do it they can try but at the end
of the day
gruden's gonna do it and he did it and
now they have to try to make some
chicken salad as their playoff hopes
melt away who's coaching for their job
in the final three games of the season
mike
because as you know there's always you
know from i say always there's
frequently the the surprise
firing uh who do you think is in fact
coaching for their jobs
right now in the nfl well i think matt
maggie in chicago is
and they did well yesterday and if
anything yesterday's game
helped gm ryan pace the guy who picked
mitchell trubisky over to sean watson
because for one day for one moment in
time
trubisky was better than watts and
although the truth is the team around
trubisky was better than the team
around watson i i i i'm not even going
to say hey if the jets happened to win
the last three years oh no maybe adam
gave stays because that team yesterday
it it they they're done now they had to
fire
greg williams to even have a chance of
winning one of their final four games i
think even with that move
it's not happening i sense that anthony
lynn is going to be out with the
chargers
they've decided not to make any moves
until after the season
but with that young quarterback and
justin herbert that becomes a very
attractive job
and frankly it's not the case but and
and i'll link two together
rich sure the bengals and the cowboys
zach taylor and mike mccarthy
both guys i believe will be back because
both owners mike brown and jerry jones
even though they
have nothing else in common the one
thing that they are linked
by is their staunch refusal to pay
someone to not work for them
so until it gets to expiration of
contract
or at least expiration of guaranteed
money under contract
zach taylor and mike mccarthy are safe
although there's been plenty of rumbling
in dallas about major changes on the
defensive side of the ball which i think
will be coming who's your coach of the
year mike
right now it's got to be kevin stefanski
nine and three with the cleveland browns
team that has been in the playoffs in 18
years and to come in with no off-season
program
no preseason games a team that that
grossly underachieved last year so he
had to
quickly reverse a negative vibe and
bring in
a new everything and it's always judged
by
how far a coach takes a team beyond
whatever the loosely held
expectations were the expectations for
the browns weren't to be nine and three
not i mean it may be to compete
potentially for the seventh seed i mean
they're they're in the driver's seat now
for the 5c they can still win the
division
miles garrett tweeted about it last week
that the steelers left the door open
after they lost to washington again
no they didn't well uh 11-2 9-3 brown's
win tonight
it could be week 17 nbc prime time for
all the marbles in the afc north between
the steelers and the browns in cleveland
what about matt lafleur though how come
he doesn't get any run
he goes 13-3 in his first year there
in green bay when everyone's wondering
if aaron rodgers can be
coached to change his spots and instead
the spot is perfect for leflore
and rogers together and the whatever
happened in the off-season with no new
receivers
and the drafting of jordan love and that
narrative is totally fizzled
and the packers are in first place in
the conference
having just clinched a division why no
run for him is it because aaron rodgers
we're still assuming you could just
still roll the footballs out for him
even though macarthur
and i think it's the fact that they were
13-3 last year and
really he should have arguably been the
coach of the year last year but
john harbaugh with 14-2 and we didn't
expect 14-2 from the ravens
you know there's a lot of coaches worthy
of it and it's unfortunate these ap
awards are just one vote
per voter and they can't do first place
second place right place like they do
for the heisman
so you can at least give people some
some broader recognition
and more names get mentioned and we can
get a better appreciation of who else
is out there that deserves it i mean
sean payton deserves it andy reid
deserves
recognition bill belichick for crying
out loud because of his failures as a gm
deserves recognition for his performance
as a coach so there are plenty of
coaches out
there this year who have have over
achieved but
when you consider all the circumstances
of 2020
for kevin stefanski to come in what
people were saying including me
josh mcdaniel should get that job not
stefanski what he's done has been
remarkable
mike thanks for the time greatly
appreciate it um and
uh always enjoy you kicking off and
ending the day here
on peacock thanks for that and thanks
for the call as always all right rich
great talking to you man right back at
you that is mike florio here
on the rich eisen show lots of food for
thought hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here